in season six of Game of Thrones ayah
says she wants to go west of Westeros to
see the edge of the world west of
Westeros is where all the maps stop no
one knows what's beyond the sunset sea
but some have tried to find out one of I
is ancestors Brandon the shipwright
sailed west across the sunset sea and he
was never seen again
his tomb in Winterfell is empty some
crazy Ironborn on the island of lonely
light believe there's a paradise in the
West land without winter or want but all
they've ever found his boundless Gracie
one of Daenerys his ancestors Queen
Rainey's Targaryen plans to fly her
dragon across the sea but she and her
dragon died before she could try so the
sunset sea is a mystery but there's one
person who went further west than anyone
else 250 years ago
Alyssa farmen was the daughter of the
Lord of Fair Isle an island off the
westerland's by the sunset sea ELISA was
kind of like Arya a rebellious wild
spirited girl she was an archer and a
singer loved horses and dogs but a great
love was sailing she spent most of her
childhood on ships as a teenager she
sailed her own boat voyaging north to
Bear Island and south to the Yabba but a
dream was to sail west and find strange
lands beyond the sunset sea Alyssa's
brother Andrew married Rena Targaryen a
widowed queen of two different kings it
was weird that a queen would marry into
a minor noble family like the farm uns
and Andrew was a pretty unimpressive
husband Raina didn't seem that into him
she was closer with Alyssa
it's hinted that Reyna was gay and the
she and Alyssa were in love so for a
year Reyna and Alyssa and friends lived
on Fair Isle there were the center of
court life and went on joy rides on
rayna's dragon dream fire but the Lord
of Fair Isle got sick of reina
dominating his Island and of her dragon
eating his shape so he asked her to
leave he wanted Alyssa to stay and get
but like Arya Alisa didn't want to marry
some Lord so she left home with Raina
for a month
they mooched off the Lannisters of
Casterly Rock and enjoyed the
hospitality of the wealthiest house in
Westeros but it turned out shockingly
that the Lannisters were scheming so
Rana and ko left the rock and toured the
westerland's and Riverlands for a while
as the young daughter of a minor noble
family ELISA got to travel across
Westeros with her love the dragon queen
but eventually Reyna settled on
Dragonstone
the Targaryen island and ELISA wasn't
happy there she wanted to build a ship
and returned to her wide Western seas
Raina refused and that relationship
broke down so ELISA left Dragonstone and
on her way out
she stole three of rayna's dragon eggs
ELISA went to Pentos and Braavos and
sold the eggs to the Sealord of Braavos
she used the money to build the ship of
her dreams
the Sun chaser designed for deep waters
and long voyages ELISA planned to sail
west the Targaryen meanwhile lost their
[ __ ] the theft of their eggs meant that
someone outside their family could get
dragons which is like someone outside
your country getting nukes they hope
that without the heat of Dragonstone
their eggs will turn to stone
that way some spice monger and pentose
will only have three very costly stones
hundreds of years later in book one of
Game of Thrones
Illyrio mopatis a cheese monger of
Pentos gives an heiress three dragon
eggs which he says have turned to stone
three stone eggs from a manga in Pentos
the language is the same hinting that
Danny's eggs are the same eggs that
ELISA stole hundreds of years ago
Daenerys is whole story might not have
happened if it weren't for ELISA Farman
but no author George Martin does say
that this is meant to be ambiguous not
certain but ELISA built her ship the
Sunchaser
and from Braavos she sailed down the
Narrow Sea dodging pirates went around
dawn and came to Old Town the city of
the city
and the Hightower oh listen you that the
tug Aryans were hunting her for their
eggs but she needed a crew people who
believed in her mission to find new
lands in the West which was difficult
because many people believe that the
world just ends in the West with walls
of fire and boiling sea saw black fogs
that go on forever but the maesters and
North Georgia Martin say that the world
of Game of Thrones is round like ours so
if the West must eventually connect to
the Far East to the lands of VT and a
shy Western trade route to these places
would be worth a fortune in silks and
spices but Alyssa's dream was bigger
than money she believed that the world
was far larger and far stranger than the
maesters imagined she envisioned new
undiscovered lands in between Westeros
and Essos with Sundering rivers and
Plains green Islands strange beasts and
golden Cities beneath strange stars
Westeros is kind of like Britain esos is
like Europe and Asia and Sethe oreos
like Africa so maybe there's a continent
to the west like America ELISA hoped to
find it as she looked for a crew Eustace
and Norman Hightower came to question
her but ELISA convinced them to join her
mission adding their ships to hers she
gathered a crew and just as the
targaryen were closing in ELISA left old
town with three ships and sailed west
three years later one ship returned
Eustace and his ship came ragged and
exhausted back to old town and Eustace
told the story of Alyssa's voyage he
said that at first it was smooth sailing
but a month in they were hit by storms
Norman's ship was struck by lightning
and sank some sailors said they saw a
Kraken but Elissa and Eustace ships
survived and they found land three small
islands farther to the west than any
known land ELISA named the islands Aegon
Visenya and Rey nice so rainy star
Garion who died before she got to fly
West had an island named for her in the
Far sunset sea ELISA explored her new
Isle
and found new spices pink fruits and
huge gray lizards with a venomous bites
ELISA wanted to sail further west to
discover more new land but Eustace and
his crew was scared and then turned back
home he Eustace spent a year stuck on
Sethe oreos and his crew almost all died
but some summer Islanders helped them
back to old town go watch our video
about Sethe oreos and the east as for
Alissa she vanished to the west still
searching for lands beyond the sunset
sea she was never seen again
except decades later a famous Mariner
called Corliss valerian visited a shy in
the Far Far East and there he glimpsed
an old and weathered ship that he said
could only have been Sunchaser Alyssa's
ship
so maybe Alissa made it all the way
across the world she could have seen new
lands and crossed the Americas before
arriving at a shy from the east and one
theory goes further in book - daenerys
meets quaithe a shadow binder from a shy
and Quaithe says to go north you must
journey south to reach the west you must
go east
just like Alisa goes west to reach the
east so some fans speculate that Quaithe
is Alyssa that she learned magic in a
shy and lengthened her life just like
Melisandre of a shy lengthens her life
may be the reason why quite felissa
helps Daenerys is because she reminds
her of Reina the dragon queen who Alisa
once loved
the whole reason why Quaithe comes to
Dani in the first place is to see her
dragons the Dragons that hatched from
the eggs that Alyssa stole so this is
just speculation but it's possible that
Alyssa farmen still lives as a two
hundred and fifty year old magician with
a cool mask and a love for geography
it's also possible that Alyssa just died
at sea or on some unknown land but what
we do know is that Alyssa rebelled
against her family and loved a dragon
Queen she traveled across Westeros and
beyond following a dream to see sights
yet on
and maybe rebellious aiya could do the
same like ELISA she could reject the
life that others chose for her she could
escape the violence and horror that she
suffered like ELISA aya could sail west
chasing the Sun of course
circumnavigating the globe takes more
than an adventurous spirit naval
navigation without modern technology
involves a lot of math geometry
trigonometry astronomy but people have
done it for thousands of years the
ancient Greeks accurately calculated the
size of the earth Columbus and Magellan
knew that the world was round
maybe Elissa farmen did too and that's
how she knew there was land to the west
maybe Elissa farmen used brilliant
brilliant is a learning site with
interactive challenges teaching maths
and science it's better than a lecture
or video because it has you actually
solving problems yourself at your own
pace with guides and solutions to help
you through it starts with basic stuff
then more advanced then whatever this is
with brilliant you can find out it's
surprisingly easy and fun to learn all
the concepts that you missed at school
and to become a little bit smarter each
day sign up for free at brilliant org
slash alt shift X the first 200 people
get 20% off an annual premium
subscription thanks for watching please
like and subscribe thanks to patrons Tom
salt will Devon Rebecca radula Katie
Bell for Jennifer Sarah heifer and rain
fernandez nico grease harbor and lurking
tyler Cheers
you